i was born in boston massachusetts and
when i was three i moved to santa
barbara california and i'm an only child
my father owned a health care consulting
firm and i had a relatively normal
childhood my parents found out that i
had add when i was five it's pretty
debilitating like i learned how to read
and write a lot
longer than my peers it took me a lot
longer to learn how to read and write
than my peers and my parents put me on
ritalin when i was five in adderall
shortly thereafter so i was on
amphetamine salts
when i was in first and second grade um
by the time i got into high school i
started experimenting with illicit
narcotics you know pg-13 drugs marijuana
ecstasy lsd
i got expelled from three high schools
within the span of a month and i spent
most of my teenage years in
programs for troubled adolescents they
sent me to wilderness programs they sent
me to residential treatment centers in
utah
and i had some writing published when i
was a teenager so i got into a program
outside of boston
for for writing it was a writing
internship program right away when i got
out there
they would give you an 80 stipend which
was like an allowance
and i started going into the ghettos to
buy heroin
i was snorting it back then
and i learned very quickly
the place where i could go scored on the
street
one day i went out there and the normal
people that were selling it weren't
around there's a black guy out there
that i'd never seen before and i went up
to him and asked him if if he knew where
i could get heroin
he had me follow him into an abandoned
building or plywood for the windows and
when we got in there we got to a
stairwell he asked me how much i wanted
i wanted 80 worth
his eyes were red it looked like he was
hopped up on something like crack or pcp
and he pulled out a gun and he accused
me of being a cop
shaking the gun at me is the first time
a gun never been pointed at me
i told him i wasn't a cop that i was
basically a college student that i just
snorted heroin
and he told me he wanted me to shoot up
in front of him to prove that i wasn't a
cop i'd never shot up in my life i had a
phobia of needles at that point
and he pulled a worn and aged syringe
out of his sock
and he forced me to shoot up at gunpoint
now i didn't know how to do it so he
just told me to put my arm out i looked
away and he shot me up for the first
time
um that was a very definitive
moment for me you know that that was a
big milestone in my life as far as
if i look back in retrospect if i could
pinpoint one moment that things started
to go downhill very very quickly it was
right when the needle was introduced
um
for a while i didn't even know how to
shoot up there was no youtube back then
you couldn't just google how to do it i
would just
stick the needle in my arm i wouldn't
even find a vein so i had these lumps
eventually i learned how to do it and
i became an iv heroin addict i got
expelled from that program and i came
back to california
abortions
with different girlfriends in and out of
jail i was homeless for a while
and i got a job brokering media for
spike tv
if you remember those shows wildest
moments caught on tape what i would do
is i would find crazy footage of like
car chases or armed robberies i would
buy them non-exclusively and sell them
to spike tv
and i became an associate producer but
what happened is my drug habits started
going up
to a gargantuan level
no drug dealers in santa barbara where i
was living could even keep up with me
anymore so i had to come down to la to
buy heroin just to sustain my habit
and i started selling drugs on a pretty
major level of selling kilos every week
i was selling kilos of mdma
cocaine
and eventually heroin because
the dealers that i had in santa barbara
couldn't even keep up with me so it got
to a point where i was making about ten
thousand dollars a week from selling
heroin
i would come down to east l.a
and the woman that i was getting it from
ended up getting caught by the feds i
didn't know that unbeknownst to me she
had caught in a federal case
she got caught with a kilo
and
in popular culture you see
the junkie get caught and tell on the
dealer on a federal indictment
they usually have a target at the very
top
so they do these big ricoh or conspiracy
cases i got caught up in a conspiracy
case
and she had told on about 40 people so i
had 65 co-defendants on the first
indictment i think 105 on the
superseding indictment and i came down
to east la to
get my normal
batch of heroin i was getting a pound to
two pounds every week
and when i met up with my connection
to a hispanic lady she looked at me and
she said
you're gonna be okay mijo there's a tear
coming out of her eye i knew right there
and then that she set me up
grabbed the bag
went back into the car to the girl that
had brought me down there
and she was sick she was going through
heroin withdrawal at the time and she
was crying she told me that i had to get
her well
i knew that we were busted
you know um
and i was trying to hurry her up but she
insisted that i shoot her up or she
wasn't going to continue to drive the
car
so i was giving her a shot and she said
cops
and we looked and we were completely
surrounded there's probably 40 or 50
cops surrounding the car they had guns
out
um one of them kept
yelling we're dead we're dead
we didn't know what that meant dead was
an acronym for drug enforcement agency
detective but they kept yelling we're
dead we're dead i've never seen that in
movies or in tv shows i had no idea why
they kept yelling it later i'd find out
that that was the acronym for drug
enforcement agency detective and when i
got out of the car i had a needle in my
hand
you know they're like dropped the needle
got down on the ground and uh they
arrested me
that was the second time that i got
caught with weight
in east l.a within a 48 hour period the
first time they let me go
second time they let me go again i had
no idea why i'd never dealt with federal
authorities before
um i didn't cooperate with them
i thought that it was probably a search
and seizure issue i just never heard of
somebody getting arrested with drugs and
being let go
i thought it was going to go away plus i
was making so much money at the time
i had this delusion that i was above the
law you know i had quarter million
dollars cash in my safe i thought that
if it ever came to a point where i was
going to court that i had enough money
to pay my way out of it
about four months later i get a phone
call from a blocked number
and
it says that it was a guy from the dea
and he said this is so and so from the
drug enforcement agency
you've been indicted you have two and
two charges against you you're facing 10
to life
you can turn yourself in or we're going
to come knock your door down
so i went and i got an attorney um this
guy named bob sanger he's one of michael
jackson's attorney spent a lot of money
retaining him
and he asked me what i want he said you
know you're dealing with federal
mandatory minimums
the best you're gonna do is five years
five to forty or ten to life i'm gonna
try to get you down to the five to forty
bracket
my girlfriend was in the car with me the
first time that i had gotten arrested so
i said
i'll turn myself in and you can make a
deal with the feds
but make sure that she doesn't get
indicted by them
so he made a deal with the dea that i
was to self-surrender down in downtown
la right here
um
and they weren't going to charge my
girlfriend
so i came down here thinking that if i
turn myself in they were going to do my
fingerprints and i was going to get out
that day maybe the next day
i didn't see the light of today for five
years
and what they did is the feds kept their
word by not charging my girlfriend
federally but they gave the case over to
the state
so the same drugs that we got caught
with they gave to the los angeles
sheriff department
and they charged her with it so now she
was a fugitive on the run
and i called
her cell phone her brother picked up and
she had overdosed and died found out
that she died because she was scared as
a fugitive on the run
because the feds essentially tricked us
into me turning myself in saying that
she'd have immunity which they never
charged her federally but they gave the
case over to the state
prison
um you know obviously i was scared you
know everything that i'd ever heard
about prison you know violence rape
riots um these were things that were
deeply embedded into my psyche
and i remember
being petrified to to go to prison i had
no idea what was going to happen to me i
saw people stabbed in there
the most violent thing that i ever saw
is
i saw somebody
poor
burning hot baby oil on somebody's eye
and their eyeball came out you know they
had put in the microwave a thing of baby
oil in a plastic cup until it got
boiling hot
the guy was sitting down playing cards
the guy tapped him on the shoulder and
poured this thing of boiling hot baby
oil on his face and his eyeball came out
um i still have nightmares to this day
of this hellacious scream it was this
whale that you never forget if you hear
somebody that's endured that kind of
violence in real life
um
you know growing up in the upper middle
class in santa barbara
violence was something that was
abstracted to me
um i remember when i started seeing
people stabbed in real life it looked
fake
you know it looked like something you'd
see in a movie blood would spray out you
know somebody would stab somebody and
hit their artery blood would spread out
and you'd think that it wasn't real but
it was actually happening
and
while i was in prison
i'm not an inherently violent person so
i try to stay out of the way
i decided that before i'd gotten
into drugs and gotten into trouble i was
going to be a writer
so i started writing a book
and i kind of clung on to that obsession
you know i was going to perfect my craft
while i was in there
and i was going to work every day to
write a book over and over again until i
had it right and i was going to put out
a novel and this novel was going to
change my life and that is what got me
through federal prison
i got out in 2013 after serving five
years um
got my book published it was called
wasting talent and it really did bring
me the life that that
i thought it would you know i started
touring i started meeting celebrities
started getting a following
and i ended up getting sober for three
years when i got out of prison
i relapsed in 2015.
um
and when i had relapsed i'd been totally
sober for three years my life didn't
have the drama associated with it when i
was in active addiction
seemed like i had everything going for
me at the time
i thought i could do acid in recovery
you know i thought that because i was a
writer i was a creative type i could do
lsd and it wasn't an addictive drug like
heroin within a week i had a needle in
my arm again my fiancee had left me
and i lost everything i lost my condo in
la within one week i lost everything
that i had
i ended up marrying um a fan i got a fan
letter from a woman that lived in denver
she said she was a big fan of my book
and she wanted to meet me
flew her out to la because i just sold
the french rights to my book and got you
know i'd come up on a
you know on a lump sum of money at the
time
we knew each other for a week and we got
married had a horrible tumultuous
marriage for a year i was doing heroin
the entire time and i was drinking two
fists of whiskey a day it's kind of
lighting the fuse at both ends
and that culminated with me
getting arrested for a dui got in a car
accident but i wasn't drunk i was
actually dope sick so the cops knew that
there was something wrong with me they
charged me with driving under the
influence
i beat it in the state but since i was
on federal probation they decided to
send me back to prison for three months
i lost everything again and that just in
that three month period i lost my
apartment my wife left me i lost my
vehicle i got out
and i moved back in with my parents in
santa barbara i was 31 years old i
didn't have a card and you know i was
living with my parents
um
my book royalties were were running thin
at that point and i started going to aaa
meetings because i wanted to better
myself
i ended up meeting a girl at an aaa
meeting she was like five years younger
than me and she her and i had a platonic
relationship she told me that she just
wanted to hang out with somebody that
was sober
we went to the beach together one day
and she told me that she was an escort
and
she asked me how i felt about it this is
not my girlfriend so
i'm a pretty non-judgmental person i
said as long as you're safe we're just
friends i don't care what you do for a
living
she called me about a week later and
asked me if she if i could hook her up
with a sugar daddy type relationship i
was 31 years old at the time i was like
i don't know people like that you know
that's
probably like an older age demographic
than the kind of people i hang out with
and she told me she was getting kicked
out of her place she really needed me to
hook her up with somebody
coincidentally a couple days after that
somebody asked me for heroin i was clean
at the time but i was doing someone a
favor by getting it for them
i went and i
met up with my heroine dealer he asked
me if i knew any escorts he said that he
drew uber
and one of his main clients was this guy
that was in an unhappy marriage
and he wanted kind of a sugar daddy type
situation with an escort
i told the girl about it because she had
been getting raped beaten on back pages
she wanted a safe arrangement
um
told her about it she asked me if i
could
introduce her to this guy the drug
dealer gave the guy my phone number he
called me i set it up for her
i wasn't making any money off of it i
was just trying to put her in a better
situation and she asked me to go with
her to the motel
turned out that um we got set up there
were six cops there six sheriffs they
had shotguns in her face the drug dealer
had set us up
and
they asked the girl what my role was in
this situation and she said oh that's my
friend ryan he just got out of prison
i'm trying to make him money which
wasn't true i don't know why she told
them that but because of that statement
i got charged with pimping and pandering
now i was on federal probation already
for the conspiracy case
it turned out that
the girl that i was buying heroin from
back when i caught my original fed case
was connected to a drug cartel called
the mendoza clan
because it was such a high profile
cartel case they kept me on supervised
probation for four years so i was still
on supervised probation for four years
when i caught the pimping and pandering
case
and they were putting a lot of pressure
on me to
take a conviction
a week after i caught that case
i sold the film rights to my book
a couple days after that
my current partner who i've been with
five years i got pregnant so i was out
on bail
just got a film deal for my book
and my girlfriend was pregnant
and it was almost
unequivocally
certain that i was going to miss the
birth of my first kid
my friend had written the screenplay for
fight club for david fincher's fight
club and he told me that
he really liked my life story the chaos
of it the mayhem
he thought it would make a good
documentary so then a documentary about
my life went into production so all of
these things happened at the same time
it was this confluence of
a lot of really positive and a lot of
really negative things
and i just had a complete mental
breakdown you know i i stopped sleeping
i'd stay up for 10 days at a time i went
into the psychosis
and eventually
um
i started acting so erratically i was
calling the fbi telling them that my
parole officer was trying to kill me
because i honestly thought that
um i got so paranoid that the feds were
after me that i started having these
like really public freakouts
my p.o didn't know what to do and he
issued a warrant for my arrest just to
try to keep me safe because they thought
that i was a danger to myself or the
community
and i went back to prison
i served 16 months missed the birth of
my first son
i got out 16 months later
and that last term was the worst term
that i'd been in i got in nine riots in
the course of 16 months i got eight
stitches three broken ribs
it was a nightmarish term
and but the worst part of that was
missing the birth of my son you know i'd
much rather enter physical pain
than have to miss the birth of another
kid
um that literally felt like it was
tearing me apart from the inside
um and when i got out i had nothing left
the documentary had been put on hold
my book sales were down
um
i got out and i tried to start you know
working conventional jobs um i went i
was working as a telemarketer i was on
welfare it was to the point where the
only way i could support my family was i
was going to churches to go to food bank
so i could get canned goods just to be
able to
feed my one-year-old in my field and my
fiance
um
at the end
i was working at this telemarketing
place and my manager was probably like
four years older than me so i'm like 33
at this point
and he yelled at me because i didn't ask
permission to smoke a cigarette
and i looked at him and i just couldn't
be talked to that way i valued myself
more than that
and i quit
i walked out of there
and
i remember my fee i called my fiance and
told her that i quit
i said you know i have a i have a higher
purpose in life than this
my fiance is like we're counting on that
we we're paycheck to paycheck in fact
we're in a deficit below that you know
we have to have those paychecks just to
keep the electricity on
and to feed our kids and i said i just
have a feeling everything's gonna be
okay
ten minutes later two things happened to
me
the first is i got a phone call from one
of my friends
um and he said that
someone wanted to meet me it was it was
a very high profile person
gave me a lot of confidence
knowing you know the person presented is
like an a-list actor and this guy
presented himself as a fan of my work
um
and the second thing was i got asked to
be on a podcast
and that podcast
from just going on that one podcast and
getting enough views um i was able to
create my own platforms create my own
following and i never worked for another
person again we had another kid
and some were in that time i i got sober
for good
um
and now i'm sitting here sober talking
to you a lot of people ask me
why they think that i went through as
much as i did considering that i come
from a background without abuse
upper middle class family
um
my parents put me on ritalin and
adderall when i was five i don't blame
them for that because that was per the
recommendation of healthcare
professionals this is when add had a
rampant diagnosis it was very pervasive
in the early 90s but what i think
happened is neurologically
being put in amphetamines when i was
five six seven eight years old it gave
my neurology this insatiable appetite
for narcotics by the time i was 15 it
seemed like when i started doing illicit
drugs it was something that i've been
missing the entire time i don't blame my
parents for that but i would certainly
ask
that if there's other parents in similar
situations having health care
professionals recommend medications to
think about it because there might be
long-term implications
for those medications
so when you when you were on the streets
and you're heavy in your drug use you
must have seen some crazy [ __ ] right
yeah when i was when i was 19
um
you know i had been
kicked out of my parents house
and i was on probation at the time for
drug possession back in that time period
if you got a dirty drug test they'd give
you 30 days then you get out you get
another drug test you get 60 days and it
would go up
incrementally like that 30 60 90.
they were trying to give me six months
in jail now i was fully addicted to
heroin at this point and i went to court
to
[Music]
for them to remand me into custody i
knew that that was a possibility that
the judge might tell the bailiff all
right we're remanding mr leone into
custody
and when they said that i was sweating
and i remember
just feeling the impending sense of
withdrawal i knew that i was going to be
very dope sick in jail and i just got up
in court and ran out of the courtroom
while the bail lift was chasing me
my parents were petrified that they were
harboring a fugitive at this point so
they won't let me live with them they
basically said go turn yourself in for
six months in jail or you can't stay
here anymore so i
basically became homeless willingly
because i was too scared to go kick
heroin cold turkey in jail
while i was homeless
i met this guy named pablo it was
probably like in his early 30s and he
was a drug dealer
and he said i could live with him as
long as i would
be the runner for him i'd go deliver
drugs for him give me a place to stay he
was in this tumultuous relationship with
his girlfriend they were always fighting
throwing you know dishes at each other
smashing everywhere it was very
uncomfortable place to live so i tried
to
be out of that house as as as much as
possible
one day they had me go to the needle
exchange
to pick up clean syringes because they
sold heroin they sold speed and they
would always give clean
syringes and tourniquets cottons
whatever to their customers so i go to
the needle exchange back in that time
period it was very clandestine because
it was still illegal at that point there
were some like humanitarian
um you know health advocates that would
like do these underground needle
exchange
programs it's like early 2000s so i go
get the clean needles they give it to
you in this brown lunch bag
and as i'm leaving the exchange
i see
a girl that i used to know that's a
stripper
she asked me if i have any heroin
she looks up at me and through this
collage of mascara you know she'd been
crying i recognized her she's pregnant
at the time
she told me that
being dope sick is worse for the unborn
child
than actually doing heroin itself
i'm dope sick too at the time
and
i had a drug dealer that lived a couple
blocks from there the guy that i was
living with i would have had to take a
bus an hour south
so i would have gotten something sooner
if i brought this girl with me to the
drug dealer's house that lived
by the exchange
so i was like yeah we can go it's a
couple blocks away morally at this point
drug addiction just completely skewed my
moral compass i don't even know if i had
one at the time i'm literally just on
survival instincts get more drugs that's
it not thinking about what it means to
get a pregnant girl drugs i'm just
thinking about sustaining my own habit
we get to the house now i already owed
the guy 60 bucks or something
i was like all right let me get the
money she pulls out this like yellow and
blue money
like what is that it was like foreign
currency she's like it's korean
like he's not gonna take korean money
and she's like just see if you know
it'll convert to 100 bucks i already
owed the guy money i knew he was going
to say no
so i go and i knock on the door
there's these like nazi skinhead guys
swastikas on their on their neck
and as soon as they see me they're like
hey do you have the 60 bucks you owe me
i was like i have a hundred dollars in
korean money they lit they took it out
of my hand and ripped it up and they
told me to get out of here and get out
of here junkie
so um
i
end up going back to the girl that had
given me the korean money to begin with
she's crying hysterical i'm like i told
you they weren't gonna give me something
she's and she goes well suck their dick
again moral compass is skewed i'm not
thinking she's pregnant you know this is
like even going
further down on the moral compass
so i go back and i'm like hey okay
she'll suck your dick they're like is
she good looking and i'm like yeah i
mean she's a stripper i
don't tell them that she's pregnant
so i bring her back
and
one of the guys had just gotten out of
prison so he wanted her to give him a
[ __ ] so i go in with them
she goes with this other guy into this
room they kind of make a comment about
her being pregnant sitting on the couch
and
kind of just waiting while she's doing
whatever she's doing
the guy that is inside the house is
smoking meth he asks me if i want any i
don't even want any i'm just a heroin
addict at that point i didn't like meth
and all of a sudden the guy runs out of
the room
and he's complaining saying that you
know she was scraping wasn't doing a
good job
and she's like let's get out of here
and the guy that i was with that was
smoking meth
goes in the room where they were and
realizes that some of his dope is
missing so he wants to like strip search
us when we get in this like verbal
altercation
i'm like you're not strip searching us
we're out of here we leave
girl pulls a few grams out of her pocket
and she's her out of her bra she's like
hey you know i stole the dough
but i left the bag of needles in the
house
so i tell her this i'm like well you
know i left i left the bag of needles in
the house and at that point there was no
way we could get other needles because
the needle exchange program is only open
at specific hours
i had tried to break into this guy's
house before
he had this window in the backyard with
this
stack of plywood leading up to it it's
like logs and plywood
and my friend and i had broken the latch
off because we had planned on robbing
this guy
so i knew theoretically i could
crawl up the log pile get into the
bathroom let myself down crawl military
style and it was possible that i could
grab the bag of needles without being
seen get back out and we'd have the dope
and the needles there's also a very good
chance that they'd figure it out but i
was willing to take that risk because i
was dope sick and i wasn't thinking
so
i go up this pile i lower myself down
military style
on the bathroom floor i open the door
slowly i can see their legs dangling on
the couch and i can see the bag of
needles it's like in my
scope of vision i know that i can grab
it without being caught
so i crawl military style going i'm
slithering
to the bag
grab it
i have to do a 180 on my stomach
and all of a sudden
i hear pink floyd's money
it's my ringtone on my cell phone going
off
right as i'm leaving
it was very quick what happened after
that but
they figured out that i was in there
throw me up against a wall
one of them punched me in the face broke
my nose so my eyes were watering i could
barely see anything all i could see was
a butterfly knife getting sliced towards
me
and somehow i broke myself free
before they could stab me
there's these concrete steps that go
from the front door
to this gravel driveway
and i jumped and they were running
right behind me and they jumped as well
and the guy dropped the knife the guy
that had the knife slipped when he
jumped because i just like jumped and
happened to get down onto the gravel
when he did it he fell
knife kind of just tumbled so i'm
looking at the knife he's looking at the
knife and it was like whoever grabbed it
first i grabbed the knife before he did
and he's just kind of looking at me like
a deer in headlights
and i stabbed him right above the
kneecap because i felt i had to i felt
if i hadn't done that that he was going
to get me
um
and the girl
that had was with me is just standing
there
she's in shock too this guy like is
literally just like you know there's
blood coming out of above his knee it
was very very gory very bloody
and it seemed like everything was in
slow motion it almost seemed like the
volume was down i remember sticking the
needle in it felt like puncturing a
pumpkin
it was really soft and then it went like
thud right at the bone
and
i just remember what that feeling felt
like it's not what i would have pictured
stabbing someone to feel like i'd never
done anything close to that violent in
my life i think i maybe have been in
like a couple fistfights it's not
something i felt good about
again it was like more survival instinct
and i ended up getting the knife and i
just threw it over the fence
went away i was wearing a wife beater it
was covered in blood and instead of like
getting out of that area
we went into a taco bell bathroom maybe
a half a block from there and we went
and shot the dope that we stole
um
no moral compass to be found
what is it about drugs that change a
person's moral compass i mean because
you come from a good family right come
from a good family no violence you have
all the trauma that a lot of people i
interviewed have had
you just got caught up in drugs and that
becomes an addiction then your life goes
haywire right
yeah you know but the moral compass goes
haywire as well yeah well there's the
moral compass aspect and then there's
also there's this panic you know like if
you're watching a horror movie a lot of
times they use in a horror film they use
the device of sound where like when
something's crescendoing it's like
and it's like this like panic you know
it's like this like amplified sense of
panic
that's what being dope sick feels like
so when you're in that kind of palpable
anxiety where you can hear sirens going
off you're literally willing to do
whatever you have to do
to get out of that state of mind because
it's so terrifying it's all-encompassing
and it like it's almost suffocating
interesting what what what have you
learned from all of your
debauchery and craziness
you know i didn't learn because you seem
very stable and level-headed right now
you know i didn't i don't think i
started learning until i had kids
you know
um because i think that they gave my
life purpose
so
before it was just
it was like i've been stripped down to
like those primal instincts of just
survival and survival for me had been
mutated to fill this
drug addiction you know it was like part
of my survival just as a normal human
being would have to satiate hunger i had
to satiate this particular appetite once
i had kids i learned that it wasn't
about me anymore you know
i was secondary and my obligation as a
human being was to provide as a parent
not just financially but morally as well
so when you talk about a moral compass
being skewed or going away entirely once
i had children i started being
conscientious of that moral compass
again and it kind of gave me direction
it was a beacon towards
a moral standpoint that i wanted to
achieve
to be a good example to my kids
and that's ultimately
what was transformative for me that's
what that's what finally clicked
was having to
be held accountable by by kids that are
essentially blameless in the entire
thing you know i want to stop the cycle
right now
it's great to hear
awesome ryan thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome thanks
for having me that's great thank you
you